we have a woman who has personally
changed my life and many others i'm in a
long line of people who've been
truly affected by this human being a
drew gooder through and through and an
elementary school teacher who i
surprised earlier in the week uh in
dallas uh it's madame patricia byrd
is here
um
patricia take it away express ask your
question the floor is yours thank you so
very much welcome
it's my pleasure to be here uh little do
you know jeff and chip and joanna that
you are
my friends
in my head
the design of my home both interior and
exterior reflects some of your design
elements
um
i have fashioned my lawrence my husband
of 43 years into a little chip
in terms of when i have a a vision a
desire an idea
he just grabs the tools and say let's
just get after it let's go it's demo day
thank you thank you yes we accept it
[Applause]
my question for the two of you is this
how do you manage with all that is your
lives
to
keep each other
priority on the front burner
first in your lives above all else above
all others
wow wow
wow that's beautiful you ready to rock
that's a hard act to follow right there
i think we should be asking you i know
question forget that forget us i say
after 18 years bottom line for us i'll
keep my portion of it simple it's just
we sincerely care and uh appreciate one
another and uh make no mistake about it
that if if if something complicated were
to come between joe and i we would give
all of this up in a heartbeat to make
sure that joe and i end this race
together on a porch somewhere
reminiscing about the good old days
hopefully that's helpful what do you say
joe for us we're always going back to
that foundation and saying does it need
to be reworked is there anything that we
need to shore up a little bit but that's
like a daily thing it's maintenance this
isn't a once a year
you know february 14th let's show each
other we love you it's it's maintenance
it's just like anything that you want
you gotta work for it and it doesn't you
don't just say this is great and it's
gonna stay great you have to work at it
you have to push for those date nights
you have to push for those coffee dates
in the morning just by the sofa by the
fireplace like whatever that is patricia
before you take off i do want to bless
you with one quick thing i just felt
overwhelmed by not only your presence
but just your you know your energy you
are just a strong beautiful woman and
i'm so thankful that you're here today
but joe and i would like to give you and
your husband ten thousand dollars and
we're gonna give that to you today and
you can spend it like a drunken sailor
or you can give it away or you can
contribute it to some foundation but we
just wanted to bless you with that
before you took off god bless oh my god
ten thousand dollars ladies and
gentlemen
come on let's go
i can't believe it
[Music]